Welcome back everyone, it’s Charlie.
This will be my Full
Last of US Episode 5 Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're doing a giveaway
for HBO Max subscription.
All you have to do to Enter
is be a subscriber
and post your favorite moment
from the episode on the video.
Careful for spoilers.
If you have not seen the episode yet,
we'll start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot,
Talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode titled
Endure and Survive, which is a quote
taken from the video game the Ellie has.
The actual quote
in the context of the game is from Ellie's
comic book she reads during the car ride,
which happened earlier
on the way to Pittsburgh
in the game on the show.
It's Kansas City there in the comic
book was called Savage Starlight,
and she talks about the plot
of the comic book with Joel,
how dissatisfied she is with the ending,
because it's a cliffhanger ending
and it's meant to be a metaphor
for their adventures together as it is
in the episodes throughout the episode.
The full quote is To the edge
of the universe and back enduring survive
in the characters in the comics speak it
after a big battle, Ellie remembers
the quote after one of their big battles
with the hunters, and during the episode
when they find the underground school,
Ellie and Sam find one of the Savage
Starlight Comics from the series
that they're currently collecting.
And she speaks the line to him
to the edge of the universe
and back
door door, survive, Dawn, Survive.
Excuse me.
Savage Starlight,
the comic I've been reading
since the hero says after Big Battle, It's
meant to be a metaphor of the way
that the kids, Ellie and Sam,
use the comic book as a way to pretend
like things aren't so bad,
to make themselves feel like superheroes,
which is meant to be a parallel
for Sam's drawings of he and his brother
as superheroes and the superhero mask
that he's wearing around.
Throughout the episode, he's
been pretending to be one of the heroes
from Savage Starlight.
This whole time, I didn't see
any big changes in the intro scene.
The actual opening
scene is a flashback to explain
the origin of the hunters in Kansas City.
We see how they overthrew Fedora,
the events of the night
that it all went down.
We get the full backstory
from both Kathleen
and Henry
throughout different parts of the episode.
Just talking about what happened
and how things played out
the way they explained it.
The Fedora military that was overseeing
the quarantine zone in Kansas
City were terrible,
like way worse than you imagine.
They abuse their power.
They abused the people
physically and metaphorically,
and that led to resistance
forming initially.
The leader of that resistance
was Kathleen's brother, Brian.
The way that Kathleen talks about him,
he was more of a positive vibes, pacifist
kind of resistance leader.
But everyone loved him.
He was super charismatic,
according to members of their group.
In present day, like Perry, for instance,
her brother never actually did anything
like never ultimately accomplished
any of the real goals that their group
had or effected any real change
in the living conditions under Fedora.
The way that Perry talks about it,
it was actually Kathleen
who was the brains of the operation,
whereas her brother was more like the face
of the resistance.
And Kathleen explains that she did
terrible things but did wind up
accomplishing all their goals.
But her leadership,
her decisions are what allowed them
to actually overthrow Pedro.
And the whole vibe
that you're meant to get from her
character is that compared to him,
she's hardcore militant.
She employed every dirty trick
in the book, did all kinds of dark stuff
that would normally haunt you
for the rest of your life.
They do a pretty good job of telegraphing
her tragic end in the episode,
like she has so many conversations about
how she wants to get revenge on Henry.
When Joel was trying
to be so understanding,
you clearly see the direction
her character is going.
Oh, she's definitely going to die
some horrible death.
But this is meant to be
the reason in present day
that Perry, the other hunters,
allow her to lead their group
because she's the one that
got the job done overthrowing Phaedra.
And it all went down so recently.
Also, big Easter Egg for the Last of US
video game.
Perry is played by the same actor
who did The voice for Joel's brother
Tommy, in the game.
He's one of many video game cameos
seen so far.
We'll see more of those in later episodes.
Just to explain the timeline, though,
Henry and Sam have only been on the run
for a short while in present day,
so the Hunters just got done
overthrowing Phaedra.
And when she's interrogating
the federal collaborators
at the beginning of the episode,
that's only 11 days ago.
So all these riots this just happened in
while that was all going down, she swore
revenge on Henry because he was forced
to sell out Kathleen's brother,
Brian, to Phaedra to obtain
leukemia medicine for his brother Sam.
He gave Phaedra, the leader, quote
unquote, of the resistance.
Kathleen implies that they tortured
and killed Brian in front of her eyes,
and it either drove her mad
or maybe she'd always been
just a little bit darker, gotten darker
because of what had happened
under federal rule for the past 20 years.
As Henry explains that Phaedra had been
so terrible, it turned the inhabitants,
like the hunters here of Kansas City,
into the quarantine zone, into animals.
And when they overthrew Phaedra,
instead of doing what
normal people would do,
like pat each other on the back
and try to make an even better version
of society, it just drove them to an even
darker place.
They got even more about like,
violence begets more violence.
Abuse begets more abuse.
As if life under Phaedra turned normal
people into monsters, into the hunters,
because they're meant to be like a dark
mirror faction to the Fireflies faction,
even though the fireflies
also do a lot of terrible stuff too.
There were a couple larger
and smaller changes to the video games
for the Hunters storyline.
One of the bigger ones was
what happened to the infected
after the fungus initial outbreak
on the show many years ago,
before the insurrection, Phaedra drove
the infected underground
and trapped in there.
So in present day,
you never see any of them above ground,
which is why so many of them come
bursting out of the underground tunnels
at the end of the episode,
like an infected pinata
during the beginning of the episode
when they're rioting
after getting rid of Phaedra.
Kathleen's speech later
reinforces the whole idea
that violence begets more violence. Abuse
begets more abuse.
When you see the hunters
start abusing the federal agents,
they start torturing and killing them,
hanging them up all over the place.
In Kathleen,
ordering the summary execution
of all the collaborators
after lying to them,
saying that they would get trials.
But to be fair, she did imply
that they would die no matter what.
Like, we'll give you trials,
but you know how that's going to go.
So if her ironic delivery of the line
wasn't clear, everything's great now.
Kansas City is free. Clearly,
everything is not great.
It's just meant to be
another example of how people are
just as bad as the infected,
which is also a reference
to an Easter egg for later
in the game for the ish character,
which I'll talk about
because it's a very special moment.
It's like one real small.
No, but it's this huge side
story in the game, this huge back story.
There's moments like that
all over the Last of US episodes.
We're like this
tiny little thing in the background
has like this ten minute backstory to it.
We see Henry using the chaos to try and
run to the doctor's hiding spot with Sam.
One of the big changes here from the game
is that Henry and Sam were not originally
from the same city
as the Hunters in on the show.
It was also Pittsburgh,
and apparently the showrunner
just really hates Pittsburgh
for some reason.
Don't know why, but that's why he made
the city Kansas City end of the game.
Sam isn't deaf
and he doesn't have leukemia.
He's like a normal little kid
that Henry's trying to take care of.
They also didn't have the whole
Kathleen versus Henry back story, too.
That was completely brand
new for the episode.
Kathleen herself
was not a character from the games,
but in the game, just like the show,
they were still trying to escape the city
they had come through
and they were just trying
to make their way west
to the other fireflies.
On the show, though they weren't
specifically looking for other fireflies,
they were just looking
to get West in the game.
The reason why Henry was so afraid
of the hunters and wanted to avoid them
is because he thought
that they would just kill Sam
because he wasn't pulling his weight
and they didn't like little kids.
Like they were just more hungry mouths
to feed and they had limited resources.
We find out that the doctor
Kathleen, just executed in episode
four, took pity on them and gave them his
shelter, which he himself got from another
Fed regard that owed him a favor.
Their storyline then catches up
with John Ellie's storyline in present day
when the doctor doesn't return.
That was also meant to be the day
Kathleen captured and shot him.
That's why he didn't come back.
And they're forced to seek shelter
in the same office building where they met
Joe and Ellie.
But the idea was, is
that Henry was trying to follow them,
and that's why
they came to the same office building,
because he was looking for Joel, thinking
that they could help each other escape.
It wasn't like they accidentally
ran into Joe and Ellie.
There were a lot of moments here
that were from the game,
but from different parts of the game.
So there's some subtle changes
in the way they meet up
and then meeting up in the office
building just in general.
In the game,
it was just a normal apartment building
and it was during the daytime
and they have a knockdown, drag out fight.
But just like on the show,
Sam is the one that has the gun on Joe
getting them to stop fighting.
Yeah, I thought you were one of them, too.
And I saw you.
If you haven't
noticed, they don't keep kids around.
Survival of the fittest.
There was also a sound based trap
like Jaws that went up outside the door.
But in the game they found that later
in the underground tunnels.
One of the other parallels
between Kathleen and Joel briefly here,
like they're going to be dark
mirrors of each other.
Joel meant to be the more positive
end of that.
Kathleen The more negative end of that.
But in both cases, they equally hate
collaborators like Joel doesn't want
have anything to do with Henry when
he finds out that he was a collaborator
until later in his character arc,
he starts opening up to him
and he starts to understand
why he did what he did and forgive him.
Whereas Kathleen, not so much.
No forgiveness happening there,
but that's one of the reasons
why Kathleen is meant to be one of
the most tragic characters in the show,
because all the characters in general
are tragic characters.
It is the Kathleen happens
to be the most tragic
because she doesn't
learn anything from her experiences and
it winds up leading to her eventual death.
You probably still be alive.
If you hadn't spent all that time
chasing Henry down,
wouldn't let all those infected escape
either.
You start to notice Perry too.
He even seems like
he wants to take pity on Henry.
And Sam's like, Do we need to worry
about these two little kids?
Like,
come on, this is way more important stuff.
We should be worried about.
When Henry and Sam meet the doctor for the
first time in his hiding spot, his line.
Why go through the trouble?
You can kill yourself.
Right here is meant to be dark.
Foreshadowing for their deaths,
because eventually he does
wind up killing himself and the brother
when they're near the city.
I already explained Sam's
superhero drawings in the connection
to Elliot Savage Starlight comic book,
but the drawings themselves are also meant
to tell their history in life
under federal law,
Like all these big fights
they had with the federal soldiers,
when they finally do meet Joel and Ellie,
their relationship is relatively similar
to what it was in the games, too.
Joel starts out
not trusting or caring about them, like,
We don't want to deal with this,
we just going to do our own thing.
He reluctantly agrees to help them
until eventually
they warm up to each other in the game.
It was the Pittsburgh Bridge
they were trying to get across.
Like that was their big point of escape.
On the show, there was a bridge
that they did reference,
but it wasn't as big
a part of the episode.
Ellie's relationship with Henry
and Sam is relatively similar
to what it was in the game.
She's happy to have them along.
Keeps bugging
Joel about letting them come to Wyoming
in the fireflies with them on the show.
Henry isn't as explicit about their plans
after escaping,
only that he wants to go west
to try and find a doctor who might be able
to treat Sam's leukemia in the game.
They straight up
wanted to go find the fireflies,
and in both cases, the game and the show.
Joel waits until much later,
before finally offering
to let them join their group
and go with him to Wyoming
and eventually to the Fireflies.
Look, I don't know
exactly how I'm getting to Wyoming.
I'm probably walking,
you know, if you want to.
Yeah.
Okay.
My brother, actually, he was a firefly.
Last I heard, he was in Wyoming.
We get there, we find him,
we find the fireflies.
What do you say you in?
Sounds like a good plan.
When Henry sees Sam laughing out loud,
enjoying himself with Ellie, remarking
on how long it's been since he's heard him
laugh.
That's also right out of the games.
The general plan for escape
by going underground was similar
to the games, too, with a few minor
changes in the way the route played out.
They weren't in the office building
when they were planning the escape,
but they did pass through an office
building on the way.
When they enter the tunnels
and find the underground school
that's right out of the games.
The history they explain on
the show is also relatively similar.
It started early on after the fungus
spread and eventually the kids either
grew old and aged out of the school
they left on their own accord
or they just died either by fungus
or some other illness.
Like, as Joe implies,
they didn't follow the rules
and they all got infected, eventually
rendering the school uninhabited.
They combined a couple of scenes
from the games with this too.
In the game,
they passed through a toy store
and Sam starts playing with toys
because he's a little kid. Of course
he's going to play with the little toys,
but Henry stops him on the show.
They kind of gave that storyline to Joel,
where the others bug him about stopping
and playing with the toys
and just chilling out.
And he reluctantly agrees.
Generally,
these scenes of them chilling out together
are pretty similar
to what they were in the games.
Ellie and Sam play with the toys.
Find the new issue of Savage Starlight.
She speaks the hero's quote to him
about survival.
The rules on the board
here are meant to be an Easter egg
for a sign
they find underground in the game.
On the wall, there's a huge Easter egg
Joel finds for a character named Ish
in the games when they're making their way
through the abandoned school area,
Joel finds a letter from a character named
Ish that reads I'm gone for a few months
and the world doesn't waste any time
going to shit. Everywhere
you turn, they're infected.
Non-Infected trying to kill you.
Mankind is back to the food chain, baby.
I'm kind of shocked.
I've survived this long.
These sewers seem pretty safe.
Limited exits. Entrances
make it easier to defend.
And if anyone gets in here,
I can lose them in the maze.
I might not be tough, but I am quick.
Maybe I just need to bide my time down
here until all get sorted out up there.
I think I'll become a sewer more man
for a while.
Wish me luck. Signed ish.
End of the games Ish was a character
that just moved into this area.
The school, after it had been abandoned,
according to Neil Druckman.
Originally,
his name was meant to be a reference
to the protagonist, Isherwood
ish Williams, in the post-apocalyptic
novel Earth Abides from 1949
by George R Stuart.
In the plot of Issues,
Life was meant to be similar to the plot
of the main character from the novel.
He also said
it was supposed to be ambiguous
as to what happened to the character
in present day,
whether or not he died or he survived
and continued on Based on the drawing,
though they make it sound like
Ish was just one of the people
who was tasked with protecting the kids
after the initial fungus
spread in the school was created.
When they're looking at the cover of the
Savage Starlight, you see the woman here.
The woman on the cover
is meant to be a metaphor for Ellie.
The person fighting with her
is meant to be a metaphor for Joel.
Joel apologizing to Henry for being mad
at him, for being a collaborator.
Another example of how he's softening up,
learning to be more understanding,
opening up to people just in general,
the positive influence of Ellie on him,
as opposed to Kathleen
who went through similar circumstances.
But it's more like her
villain origin story.
And when Henry is explaining
the truth of his back story
and how he became a collaborator,
what happened with Brian and Kathleen?
His whole arc with Kathleen is meant to be
a metaphor for Joel's relationship
with Ellie
and things that he will be driven to do
in the future, decisions
he'll be forced to make.
Because as Kathleen talks to him
later, like,
well, she's got the gun on him
before she dies, that terrible death,
Kathleen starts
talking about the needs of the men versus
the needs of the few
in how Henry chose his brother.
Over the good of the many, Joel
will be forced into a similar situation
where he has to decide
whether or not Ellie's safety is worth
the rest of the human race.
Did it feel good
the train your neighbors to Federer
so that you could get medicine
for kids die?
Henry They die all the time.
You think the whole world
revolves around him,
that he's worth
everything.
And I think that whole arc like everything
they did, including Kathleen
with the whole backstory
with Henry, was for a future
twist towards the end of the season.
No spoilers about what that is.
We can talk about it again
during the finale,
but I specifically think
some of those moments were meant to set up
that big twist at the end of the season.
And what will happen is that his time
with Henry and Sam and listening to
what Henry did, why he did it will help
inform his choices in the future.
For better and worse, Joel does wind up
doing a lot of very controversial things.
You really start to see how crazy Kathleen
is, though,
when they go back to her inside her
childhood room.
And it just seems like
she is stuck in the past,
metaphorically and literally, like she's
standing in the past, metaphorically.
Her whole speech
about not doing what her brother wanted.
He told me to forgive Henry,
but no way I'm going to do that.
They really wanted to telegraph her death
during this episode.
Like, okay, this is the hundredth time
she's talked about chasing Henry down
and not for giving him probably going
to be dying at the end of this episode
when they come aboveground
and they run into the sniper.
This housing area is similar
to that part of the game where Joel
also has to sneak into the house
and take the sniper out.
And during another part of their flight,
Henry and Sam try to bail on
Joel and Ellie, leaving them behind
on the show that only lasted for a minute.
They ran right back in the game.
It just took a little bit longer
before they met back up.
Also in the game, after Joel
takes out the sniper, he uses the snipers
position in the rifle
to take out other hunters from a distance.
But there weren't nearly as many hunters,
and they didn't
have a giant fountain of infected
pouring out of the ground.
But in the game, this is where Sam did
get bit while they were trying to escape.
They just did a little bit differently.
There was a bridge on the show
that they had to cross,
but it wasn't quite as big
as it was in the games.
They pay off a moment from way back
in episode four, where Ellie asked Joel
about the military plows
when the hunters try to plow her down
literally in the others,
it even has the word run written on it.
Then the truck blows up and allows
the infected to escape the underground
tunnels.
The blunder here
is actually something that they say
from the games that originally
they fought way back at bills.
Blowers are meant to be a future evolution
of the infected with ultra tough hides
that are resistant to bullets.
And in the game
they also throw spore bombs.
They're not doing spores on the show,
though,
the way they're using the blood
or the show, though
he's more like a berserker,
like a tank in fungus form.
Look,
some of the practical effects here, too,
like the little girl that almost got Ellie
being the one to take out.
Kathleen also really happy We finally got
to see some infected in this episode.
There were a couple of episodes.
We really didn't get that many infected.
Then after they escaped,
This is all right out of the game.
The way the rest of the episode goes down.
For the most part,
they hole up in a motel.
Joel offered to let them join the group
permanently earlier in the game,
but it's the same concept,
he tells them the rest of their plans.
You can come with us if you want.
Ellie also ends the night having fun
with Sam in the conversation
that Sam has with her about being afraid
in whether or not the infected
remember their lives as humans.
Is there a human still inside the monsters
exactly the same
as it was in the game,
still inside.
How is it that you never scared?
Who says that? I'm not one of the
people that are still inside.
What if they're trapped in there
without any control of their body?
Scared of that happening to me?
One of the minor changes
here, though, is in the game.
He didn't reveal to her immediately
that he'd been bitten.
He just attacked her the next day.
You don't see he's infected
until after he's turned into a runner.
But just like in the game,
Henry is the one to kill him.
Then, horrified at his actions, turns
the gun on himself.
R.I.P. Henry and Sam.
I feel like the actors on the show
did a great job.
It was very close to the version
of the video game on the show.
They actually do wind up showing you
that they buried the bodies
and left the sorry note
because she believed that her blood
would cure his infection, which it didn't.
I also think the TV show added that moment
with the sorry note in her
trying to use her blood to cure him
for something that will happen
at the end of the season
to set up like a big twist
and make it a little more believable.
Also, please don't put spoilers for that
in the comments.
We'll talk about it later this season.
The ending song over the credits
this time was Fuel to Fire by Agnes Oboe,
which is a reference to the big fight
that they just had
with the fire
and the infected coming for them.
I don't think the song was used
in the games,
but most of the music on the show
has some connection to the games.
If there's any Easter eggs or references
that you spotted in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My Episode six
trailer video will post next
in my full Episode
six video we'll post next week.
I believe they're going back
to the regular schedule and episode
six will be on Sunday next week.
There'll be a ton of Super Bowl trailers
dropping this weekend.
Of course, we'll do videos for everything.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for the Last of US.
Episode six Video or update the link
as soon as I post that video
and click here
for all my other Last of US episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.